signé mais east au président de sud
radio bonsoir didier maïsto merci d'être
avec nous alors manifestement l'union
sacrée est rompue l'opposition en tout
cas jean luc mélenchon et marine le pen
qui assure ne pas avoir été consulté
comme l'affirmé l'exécutif ça fait tout
de même un petit peu désordre
oui toute façon c'était ce premier tour
j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire une
mascarade puisque le mot est un peu
usité au lever aujourd'hui il fallait
pas tenir ses élections municipales
c'était criminelle les gens les plus
avisés l'on dit d'abord on savait que la
participation serait très faible et
ensuite on avaient modélisé les
scientifiques avaient modélisé nous
savions que nous allions être dans le
pic les duos enfin dans le début en tout
cas du pic de court la virus et que
comme constitutionnellement il faut
impérativement que le premier le
deuxième tour ait lieu une semaine après
le premier tour il était couru d'avancé
que ces élections allaient être allez
être reportée allait être annulé ce qui
est beaucoup plus grave
ça c'est de la politique politicienne
parce qu'aujourd'hui tout le monde
essaie de finalement de sauver un petit
peu les meubles et ses ouailles ce qui
est beaucoup plus grave c'est que en
autorisant de ces élections on a mis des
millions de gens dans la rue en leur
faisant croire que parce qu'ils avaient
leur petit stylo bic dans la poche
il était protégé et ensuite comme ça
c'est la mode politicienne
les politiciens ont dit en réalité les
gens ne sont pas raisonnables ils sont
allés dans les parcs
oubliant complètement passant sous
silence le fait que ce jour là il
s'était déplacé par millions c'est tout
à fait irresponsable
avant pendant et on le voit aujourd'hui
après puisque la classe politique
n'arrive pas à se hisser à la dimension
du problème et continue à être ce câble
est en fait un peu parasitaire
puisqu'elle n'a pas prévu elle n'a rien
organisé nous le voyons pénurie de
masques pénurie de respirateurs et
aujourd'hui la panique dans l'urgence
aucune stratégie parce qu'une stratégie
se prépare bien d'amour et l'a donc ce
qu'il faut bien comprendre ça je vois
peu de gens qui le dit le soulève et y
font la chaîne delà de la cause de la
course et quand ce qu'il faut bien
comprendre c'est que le confinement
bien sûr qu'aujourd'hui il est efficace
mais ces larmes de la dernière chance
parce que quand vous êtes obligés de
confiner les gens c'est que vous n'avez
pas d'autres solutions il ya des pays
comme taiwan ou la corée qui était très
impacté au départ la corée qui ont pris
des mesures drastiques est aujourd'hui
avéré simplement de professeurs comme le
promet sans raul qui le disent il faut
évidemment il aurait fallu tester tout
le monde on savoir
et pas simplement attendre les cas les
plus sévères parce que là on est bon ils
sont justement ne teste pas j'en parlais
avec le professeur tout à l'heure
effectivement l'om est se recommande
chaudement de tester les gens puisque
l'organisation mondiale de la santé dit
en gros le confinement ça va freiner
mais pas à éradiquer
pourquoi votre avis on ne teste pas les
gens en france par manque de moyens sans
doute par manque de moyens évidemment et
par manque d'anticipation
imaginez quand même mais ça c'est le
fruit de politiques que l'on aime depuis
des décennies on a confié toute notre
industrie
à l'étranger on est incapable
aujourd'hui de produire des masques on
est incapable de produire des
médicaments penser que la la la
pénicilline tous les principes actifs
sont essentiellement fabriquée en inde
ou en chine
on a tous tout laissait chi les deux
cerveaux notre capacité de production
que voulez-vous aujourd'hui bien sûr
qu'à des mensonges donc dans l'urgence
on bricole des solutions j'étais encore
s'adapter vite il est de trouver des
maximes pharmacie ils n'ont aucun mal
les personnels soignants n'ont aucun mal
alors bien sûr il ya maintenant les
usines notamment françaises qui bosse à
plein temps et le produire des basques
et le gouvernement ne cesse de dire il
n'y a pas de carences et c'est
évidemment qu'il ya pas de masque
évidemment qu'il ya pas de gel et plus
grave encore
évidemment il n'y a pas de respirateur
artificielle parce que nous sommes
aujourd'hui comment ne teste pas les
gens en attend qu'ils soient
complètement malades dans des formes
sévères
c'est pour cela il faut bien comprendre
relation de cause à effet que les
services de réanimation sursaturé quand
vous êtes en réanimation
il faut bien comprendre que c'est grave
et qu'elle si vous n'avez pas de soins
vous passer l'armé à gauche
donc aujourd'hui seuls les respirateurs
artificiels
quand vous êtes un tube et que vous
devez respirer parce que c'était une
forme sévère de la maladie les savoureux
aiguë respiratoires un peu comme commune
strass un buisson qui sont des cousins
donc en fait vous avez la même chose
vous ne pouvez pas respirer si vous
n'avez pas ni la capacité d'accueil les
ni le matériel adéquat
nous sommes aujourd'hui dans la panique
s'est pas de choix de l'avoir dit il ya
plus d'un an que les personnels
hospitaliers sont en grève
tout le monde l'a dit des médecins chefs
ça n'était jamais arrivé ont démissionné
parce qu'il dise on n'a pas les moyens
et réductions de coûts réduction de
cours et une sur le coût total
aujourd'hui dans l'urgence on est obligé
de distribuer soit disant des milliards
mais on verra bien on fera de la dette
on n'a pas anticipé
donc maintenant il faut bien voir le
confinement bien sûr nous n'avons plus
le choix et on verra l'efficacité mais
en fait c'était bien en allemand qu'il
fallait prévoir et je les dédie depuis
lundi peu difficile à prévoir quand même
merci pas tellement parce qu'il ya des
pays
le qu'ils ont prévu et qui ont toutes h
et bien géré la crise mais c'est au
président d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france